ja ich werde in diesem monat zum dritten
mal geimpft träger also die berühmte
booster impfung termin ist gemacht wird
passieren und trotzdem
sage ich hände weg von sahra wagenknecht
und der schweiz die ja nicht geimpft
sind und die im moment von einem
meinungs- terror überzogen werden den
ich für unerträglich halte
ich frage mich woher kommt das warum ist
die politik so besessen von dem thema
und warum macht sie das zur staatsaffäre
mein eindruck ist dass die pure existenz
der weiten dass die einfach da sind als
bekannte persönlichkeiten die sich dem
allgemeinen
impfzwang indirekter art widersetzen
alleine ihre pure existenz zeigt schon
dass die verunglimpfung der impfgegner
als rechtsradikale querdenker
verschwörungstheoretiker unhaltbar ist
das zerstört diese erzählung die wir
jetzt seit monaten hören die ausgrenzung
dieser menschen und ich finde dass man
den balken wagenknecht und kimmig dafür
sogar dankbar sein muss dass man das
jetzt erkennt dass es jeder erkennen
kann was dahinter steckt und ich fahre
ich bin der meinung jetzt reicht's es
ist genug passiert es sind weit über 80
prozent der deutschen geimpft oder
gelesen das ist eine ordentliche quote
jetzt geht es nur noch um die booster
impfung für die älteren für bestimmte
probleme truppen auch in krankenhäusern
und heimen das muss passieren aber wer
sich bis heute nicht hat impfen lassen
er lässt sich nicht mehr impfen das
passiert nicht mehr und deshalb bin ich
der meinung
alle die die jetzt immer noch an die
ungeimpften hin reden und sie
niedermachen an der spitze der
regierungssprecher und die bundes
tags präsidentin und der unvermeidliche
karl lauterbach und jetzt auch noch die
parteispitze der linken
den muss man sagen haltet die klappe das
thema erledigt wir müssen dazu übergehen
diese leute kollektiv zu verteidigen
denn das wissen wir ja die freiheit ist
immer die freiheit des andersdenkenden
so ist es deswegen tut unserem land
weniger history gut wir erleben eine
aufgeregtheit gehe auch zur spaltung
unseres landes führt und das kann man
gerade an der debatte sehen ich fand es
wohl tun dass die kanzlerin gesagt hat
auch der sportler kimmig ist zunächst
bürger dieses staates ist ein gutes
recht zu entscheiden sich nicht impfen
zu lassen ich glaube das problem was bei
ihm ganz speziell entstanden es ist dass
er auch teilnehmer einer impfkampagne
ist und ein bisschen ist es so wie
vorhin bei dem klimagipfel auch wenn ich
natürlich selber wäre für eine idee aber
sie selber bei mir sozusagen außen vor
lasse dann kann das sein dass dann viele
zweifel warum soll ich sind macht es ja
auch nicht mehr wirkt so war mir aber
eigentlich auch nicht überzeugt und das
ist schon was die idee wer überzeugen
will muss auch selbst ein stück
überzeugt sein dann fehlt das ein stück
aber es muss jeder seine eigene freiheit
sein da bin ich bei ihnen das zu
entscheiden wir müssen als politik nicht
hysterisch darauf reagieren was sagen
jetzt wagenknecht oder was sagen andere
wir müssen die schützen die in gefahr
sind die sich impfen lassen können weil
die antikörper nicht gebildet werden
müssen die schützen die zu alt sind und
so schwach sind deren immunsystem nicht
mehr die kraft hat antikörper zu bilden
da müssen wir uns kümmern deine aufgabe
machen deswegen ist eine booster impfung
kampagne jetzt wichtig für die die man
brauchen die über 70-jährigen aber es
geht ja auch schon tiefer jetzt nicht
krieg morgen auch als ehemaliger
krebspatienten meine dritte impfungen
ich bin auch froh darüber weil es dann
wieder nimmt statt es gibt ja mir
sozusagen schützt das die antikörper
gebildet werden können muss aber jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden wie er
damals immer ein bisschen mitnehmen auch
wenn er sich nicht impfen lässt muss er
wissen es geht nie um ihn alleine es
geht immer auch um die anderen aber
nicht durch drucke stichwort wohl nicht
durch öffentliche ächtung wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass menschen in
abweichende meinung haben die auch
äußern absolut surfen denn das muss in
dem land selbstverständlich sei es leid
und also ist es nicht mehr fasste thomas
ketzerisch darauf schon auch reagieren
und sagen 14 monate mehr als 14 monate
18 monate über 18 monate 20 monate haben
ja politiker eigentlich das leben von
uns ein bis ins kleinste mühe
hineingeredet und plötzlich steht da ja
schon kimmig ein erfolgreicher echt
extrem guter fußballspieler und sagt mir
von euch dass ich mir jetzt gar nicht
sagen was ich zu tun habe und dieser
aufschrei dienst angegeben hat das war
natürlich
symbolisch für das was wir davor erlebt
haben nämlich diese verliebtheit jedem
zu sagen was zu tun ist und plötzlich
gibt es diesen kimmig wie kann er nur
sich gegen das verwehren also symbolisch
für den etatismus den wir erlebt haben
für den dominanten start der plötzlich
gleich damit zurecht kommt dass es sehr
sehr populäre menschen in diesem land
gibt die gar nicht unbedingt jeder will
jeder geimpfte muss sich bewusst sein
was heute den ungeimpften passiert
passiert ihm selbst morgen bei einem
ganz anderen thema wenn das so zu sagen
dieser demokratie üblich wird das große
mehrheiten kleinere gruppen ausgrenzen
und kalt stellen und niedermachen und
mit meinungs- terror überziehen dann ist
diese demokratie gescheitert deswegen
tut das ja gut dass die debatte gibt
wenn sie nicht hysterisch geführt ja es
ist wichtig dass auch andere meinungen
zur geltung kommt dass darüber
debattiert wird das führen wieder und
die ganzen argumente von kimmig können
ja auch falsch sein fachlich ich habe
bin kein biologe wird es auch gar nicht
sein will das gar nicht bewerten
vielleicht sind seine argumente
stichhaltig vielleicht auch nicht aber
für eine debatte darum und wir müssen
akzeptieren dass jemand auch eine andere
meinung hat abseits des mainstreams aber
deswegen dass er keinen körting auf
sofort sehen sagt sie als kein
rechtsradikaler war dass bürger dieses
staates der eine eigene meinung haben
muss man ihm zugestehen
aber sie haben vorhin die kanzlerin
gelobt dass sie so souverän reagiert
habe sie hat aber erstmal ihren
regierungssprecher steffen seibert
vorgeschickt der öffentlich erklärt hat
er hoffe auf einen sinneswandel bei
handke mich da frage ich mich was geht
das in regierungssprecher
das ist wirklich die privatsache von
herrn kim ich hätte mich ist ja kein
inhaber eines pflegeheims dessen
26-jähriger kerngesunde durchtrainierter
fußballer der mehrfach die woche
getestet wird da hätte er selber zeigen
müssen verzeihung es geht mich einfach
überhaupt nichts an das ist die
privatsache und punkt und jetzt will
auch die bundestagspräsidentin kaffee
trinken gehen mit gemischten nicht dass
mich die
bundespräsidentin zum kaffee zitiert
weil ich mich nicht impfen lasse ja wo
kommen wir denn da habe ich gesagt die
politik nicht einfach es geht uns jetzt
einfach nichts an wir haben allen das
angebot gemacht das hat man ja übrigens
auch hoch und heilig versprochen wenn
jeder sein angebot hat dann fallen alle
regeln das angebot hat und ich natürlich
längst kassiert im kanzleramt wollte man
nichts von wissen und jetzt braucht man
weiterhin auf 2g und 3g obwohl diese
regeln wissenschaftlich längst widerlegt
ich hab mir gerade vorgestellt wie sieht
das aus wenn die bundestagspräsident im
jetzt gebt mir ein lädt der sich impfen
lässt auf den kaffee dann wird es eine
riesen lange schlangen harris megawatt
geplant
nein das sieht man auch dass gibt die
auch nichts an am ende des tages das ist
der punkt dass selbst so sagen eine
debatte auf eine ebene geführt wird wo
sie nicht hingehört der deutsche
staatsbürger der staatsbürger kimmig
sein recht wahrnehmen sie sich impfen zu
lassen ist seine sache auch seine
verantwortung was damit seinem umfeld
tut wenn der leute dabei sind die
vielleicht anfälliger sind für
krankheiten muss also selbst abwägen und
die leute müssen das abwägen wie sie ihn
kontaktieren aber diese politik ebene in
berlin geht das wirklich nichts an was
da stattfindet es ist kimmig scheitert
die stigmatisierung von abweichlern als
rechtsradikaler und querdenker und und
spinner ja die ist hier gescheitert dann
ist es erkennbar der passt in keine
dieser kategorien das ist ein junger
mann der eine abweichende meinung hat
sowie sarah wagenknecht ihre abweichende
meinung hat das ist zulässig ich bin zu
diesen das ist mir dann wieder durch den
kopf gegangen ich bin zu querdenker der
muss in berlin hin gegangen weil ich
nicht anfangen übernommen habe was mir
da erzählt wurde dass es lauter das sind
also tausende von rechtsradikalen haben
sie mit demonstrierten sie nein ich hab
mal angeguckt habe nicht demonstriert
ich hab' ich bin dahin gegangen um sie
mir anzugucken und da gibt es zwar da
gab es eine nach meiner wahrnehmung
kleine minderheit von rechtsradikalen
unbezweifelbar schon erkennbar an den
fahnen an den an den slogans und
ansonsten war dort ein breiter
querschnitt von menschen aus der
bevölkerung da waren auch eltern mit ihr
mit kindern die wegen der der der
schulschließungen und der kita
schließungen besorgt und nicht wussten
wie sie mit den kindern zurecht kommen
wollten hier also ein eigenes anliegen
hatten und völlig in ordnung waren